[gunshots]
MAN: Let's recycle again.
MAN: [inaudible]
You good?
I'm golden.
MAN: I warned you
not to contact him.
Jesus.
Nasry won't talk
to anyone else.
I run the asset.
MAN: Out of the question.
I'm not negotiating.
I'll forward the
text to the lab.
And I want a legal
finding in writing
from the president
authorizing the assassination
of the prince.
MAN: You're more trouble
than you're worth.
The FSB has your
safehouses pegged.
They don't know my network.
Just trust me.
MAN: Word just came
in from higher.
We're on the hook for
another shot at Andrew Hall.
Nasry?
MAN: Yeah, he contacted the CIA.
Hell just froze over.
As soon as the OGAs chime in,
I'll let you know, all right?
Short leashes, no drinking.
All that [audio out] with
your home lives, do it.
You're not ready.
They're the guys.
They're loyal.
They see what they want to see.
But me, I see things clearly.
What do you see?
A selfish prick so desperate
to get back on this team you're
willing to risk all our lives.
MAN: What the hell were you
thinking giving my wife a gun?
It's my family, it's my call.
Do you understand?
You're going to
hit me, hit me.
I understand, Buddha.
MAN: Thought I'd get
some skulls of my own.
Figured it's a better way
to keep counting, you know?
We're not keeping score, dude.
You're victims.
This guy?
Yeah, he deserved it.
So did this one; blew
up a school in Peshawar.
But this?
That's a mom.
Lost her entire family.
But she came at me with an empty
gun, so I shot her in the face.
[inaudible] in Harvard,
too late for me.
But I got to believe
you've got more to life
than making your body a
[audio out] scoreboard.
MAN: What's going on, man?
I know you.
What happened?
MAN: This kid fought beside us.
[gunfire]
When the whole thing was
over, all of the villagers
took turns killing this guy.
[screams]
With stones.
Don't do it.
The kid took his own turn too.
I joined the SEALs thinking
I could make a difference.
This kid made me
realize I never will.
When are you going to
tell them that your head's
going to explode?
I love you, but
I need this for me.
I'm sorry.
MAN: Karma.
[non-english speech]
Azerbaijan is filled with
American military advisers.
I grew up in a village in the
northeast called [inaudible]..
Far away from Uncle
Sam's mercenaries.
There's an old copper mine
there worked by my father
and my father's father.
We'll regroup there.
WOMAN: I think he
ditched the phone.
MAN: OK, pack your bags.
MAN: Sheriff!
WOMAN: Rescuing Hall is
our operational goal.
Then capturing or
killing the prince.
And what about Nasry?
You will not kill him.
He's our asset.
Are we clear?
We're clear.
WOMAN: Nasry's
inside, eighth level.
MAN: Push that to
the assault teams.
[beep]
MAN: I see Hall!
Leave him or we're dead.
[gunshots]
[shouting]
MAN: Hey, we got Hall!
Take us out!
Sir?
I have multiple tangos
moving toward delta.
Jesus, it's an ambush.
[gunfire]
Get a fire mission
on them, get Golf
and Hotel back on the ground.
[blast]
[gunfire]
Viper 3-3, get daps
on those tangos!
Moving to the OC now!
[gunfire]
Sir, let's go!
MAN (ON RADIO):
[inaudible],, let's go!
[grunts]
Come on, come on, come on.
MAN (ON RADIO): Dragon
1, this is Dragon 51.
It's too hot.
We are [inaudible]
the extraction point.
Negative, we have two
eagles on the ground!
Bear!
[shouting]
Pull it down!
Put it down!
Ah-ah-ah!
[whimpering] Oh.
I'm sorry, Bear.
No worries, brother, OK?
We're here with you.
All right, Armin?
We got you, bro.
[helicopter flies]